president Trump hammering Democrats with
a stern a midterm message come election
day Americans will remember a Kavanagh
and they will remember all sorts of
other things because that was a shameful
act this will be an election of
Cavanaugh the caravan law and order and
common sense but the choice could not be
more clear
Democrats produce mobs Republicans
produce jobs Democrats however don't
seem to be able to get on the same page
for example Texas Senate hopeful beta
O'Rourke is doubling down on impeaching
Trump I would like in impeachment - an
indictment there is enough there to
proceed with the trial for a full
vetting of the facts and to make the
best informed decision in the interests
of this country and our future senator
spartacus Cory Booker is making this
bizarre claim that Canada is more
American than America
[Laughter]
and then there's Nancy Pelosi explaining
why she doesn't really care if socialist
policies hurt Americans I think that we
owe the American people to be there for
them for for their financial security
respecting the dignity and worth of
every person in our country and if
there's some collateral damage for some
others who do not share our view well so
be it but it shouldn't be our original
purpose all right Dana Smorgasburg of
democratics of Democrats trying to grasp
it anything to the message before the
election two of those cory booker and
beta O'Rourke are really running for
2020 right Nancy Pelosi is probably the
most message disciplined out of all of
them and she remembers she's the one
who's saying we're not gonna do
impeachment like everybody's like to
stop that and beta O'Rourke is actually
he's saying that an indictment and
impeachment are the same thing which is
just legally not true and he should know
that if he's running for Senate I do
think that if he ends up losing in Texas
you will see him on all of the shows for
the next week where the host will beg
him to run in 2020 and president Trump
should want that to happen because that
is not a strong message Cory Booker
where is he giving that speech he's in
South Carolina he in South Carolina
because he's helping congressional
Democrats who are really wanting to or
challengers or Republicans because they
really want to win and he's that's not
happening in South Carolina
unlike Lindsey Graham for example he's
going out on a 12 state tour after
Kavanagh so he can do all of those
things President Trump said his closing
argument is going to be Cavanaugh the
caravan law-and-order and common sense
now I think that's saying a closing
argument two and a half weeks until the
election in this new cycle is a little
risky because by Saturday we could have
a new closing argument because if you
think about it Cavanaugh was just two
weeks ago but the Democrats they're
bailing out of three important races
today down in Texas 23rd that's will
hurd seat he's looked that was a
district that Hillary Clinton won but
now he's pulling ahead so the Democrats
are gonna take money out of that try to
put it somewhere else that's happened
also in Nebraska too and Minnesota 8 so
places where the Democrats were thinking
they could have pickups those are now
out of reach for them possibly of course
it depends on turnout but if they're not
gonna put money and that shows something
the Democrats closing message is going
to be this health care specifically
pre-existing conditions which we could
talk about more if you wanted and if you
see their ads are starting to say check
on President Trump they want to vote for
a check on President Trump so if you're
a challenger to a Republican who's
already in Congress the are the ad would
say Jesse Watters votes with President
Trump 98 percent of the time you don't
want that do you
and that's how they're trying to
motivate the base Republicans out there
just 98 percent yeah well you're a
little catch a little on a couple things
just to you know keep it interesting I
think that um Republicans if you see
their ads it's immigration mm-hmm and
support for President Trump so this idea
that this is not about President Trump
it's it just really is he should embrace
it he is basically out on the campaign
trail all weekend and I think that the
Republicans if they can keep focused a
lot of the races that Democrats thought
they would be able to win will be out of
their reach whoa what do you think about
the midterms Gregg I try not to think
about him that much I got other stuff
going on because it's your job I got a
weekend coming up gonna have some fun
the great thing about when you watch the
rally you know what Trump's message is
it's really simple yeah you know it's
national security crime and borders it's
law and order
it's really hard to find out what the
Democrats are for you only know what
they're against him and they're also
against being out of power so that leads
you into the into the arena of what
Nancy Pelosi said which was particularly
loathsome that collateral damage is
acceptable and we know this we know that
the end justifies the means by any means
possible they need their power so you
saw that what Cavanaugh you know they're
his family collateral damage right if
you look at what's happening now with
the caravan the collateral damage are
those people who may suffer grave injury
trying to cross a river or being
sexually abused but they want that
spectacle right they want that so that's
collateral damage they
want to raise taxes and increased
regulation that hurts businesses
collateral damage we go back all the way
to Obamacare right collateral damage you
lost your doctor your rates went up but
that was collateral damage because the
idea of government running healthcare
was such a big idea
it didn't matter if you lost your doctor
so their message it's not about ideas
it's not about progress it's about power
by any means necessary and when you have
that ideology that means collateral
damage is not just acceptable it's
practically the only thing you have
they're not Democrats they're damaged
crats
I'll let you respond to that thank you
well I mean it's to me the the shocking
point is that Republicans don't have a
message right now so the the president
yesterday comes out and says this
message is going to be Cavanaugh and
Caravan he could have thrown in there
Kaepernick and Kanye I'm he could just
get this gone full rapper
McKay's forecast yeah because he's he is
right now struggling with the absence of
a message and you look at the
advertising that's being put on the air
everybody thought it was gonna be all
about tax cuts for the Republicans they
were gonna say we delivered on a tax cut
for the forgotten man what you see is
that Republicans are not running
commercials about tax cuts because
they're not having any traction with the
voters so that means that you go back to
red meat you go back to the most kind of
cultural war issues you can find and for
Trump you know his number one hit on the
road has always been immigration bill
the wall go after him and that's what
he's trying to do so he's trying to get
his base revved up for the midterms with
these kind of red meat issues but it's
so far that the big absence is that
Republicans don't have a strong message
and when they thought they were going to
have a message and I tell you even on
immigration anything's true even on an
immigration issue at the White House
they're having big fights between John
Bolton and John Keller the chief of
staff over why is it despite all it the
president has done in all of his
rhetoric we've seen a spike in terms of
people coming and crossing okay so they
can't figure out what the right policy
would be at the White House but they
want to say it's the Democrats this is
the most incredible thing Trump says
it's the Democrats who are paying
to have the caravan come Jesse this is
ridiculous absurd but I guess some
people might be suckers out there and
buy that kind of foolish well I mean
people are going down there from America
this garrison come north that's a fact
it's been reported in an article which
all cracks raised you know just before
we get to Kennedy just I want to address
you say about the tax cuts Gregg brought
it up you don't have to say tax cuts
when he says jobs when he says the
economy when he says GDP that's under
the umbrella of everything he's done
economically yes and that's the message
is getting across that include drive up
the deficit 17 percent in one year know
what well as a Republican I think Oh
deficits don't matter because it's not a
Democrat in the White House Oh what is
the ideas coming from the left
no but one brings up a really good point
and the problem is as an independent
voter and a woman who doesn't fit neatly
into any category or box
I look at freedom killing deficit
spending and it is atrocious from both
parties and they are so similar in that
regard because it really is this is the
thing that is going to hamstring
generations and really curtail economic
mobility which is critical for things
like hiring new employees and going out
and spending money and when you talk
about consumer optimism which has been
one of the big drivers for the economy
and for the stock market that is
completely stifled when we finally get
the bill for this outrageous money that
we're spending on everything and knowing
Paul Ryan came into power as this wonky
spending you know he was a person who
neutralized spending and talked about
cutting costs and the the debt is now 21
trillion dollars when Nancy Pelosi goes
out and when she is the mouthpiece for
this party and when she talks about the
house is going to once again rest in
Democrat hands that rivals up
Republicans more than anything and
independents because she's not a likable
person she's not only unlikable she's a
person who doesn't have a message and
you can joke that Republicans don't have
a message and you may not agree with it
but something as simple as jobs not mobs
that resume
people because they would much rather
have jobs and money for their kids then
run up against a wall of protesters who
are going to call them names and spit on
them and stop their car and vandalize
nice cities thing about Cory Booker
because we kind of skipped over it he
said that Canada is more American you
see where that they don't have her First
Amendment I think he should go back and
look it up because their freedom of
speech in Canada is not absolute their
government can pass laws that they feel
a reasonable to limit your speech so he
should probably take that true dad
Spartacus wants to roll on Canada first
let them just wanted to say you know I
agree with you Pelosi is not popular
especially with Republicans they can use
her in the ads but what about Mitch
McConnell saying oh yeah if the
Republicans get retained control we're
gonna go after Social Security met you
think that's a helpful message for
Republicans yes never speak ill of
cocaine Mitch we love it